OK.
This is a risky segment for me to do.
Why is it risky?
It's risky because it's wonky and it's technical,
and I don't know that people will like it.
This might be the type of segment that ends
up with, like, you know, 5000 views on YouTube,
but about 10 people have emailed me and they've
asked me to do this.
They've requested this.
So let's do it.
We are going to talk about two mechanisms
which Donald Trump and other rich people can
use to reduce the amount they pay in taxes.
The two mechanisms are tax loss, carry forwards.
Please don't glaze over.
Tax loss, carry forwards and asset depreciation.
OK, so Donald Trump's taxes were leaked by
this blockbuster New York Times report in
that New York Times report.
We learned that there were some years like
2016 and 2017 when Donald Trump paid 750 dollars
in total federal taxes total for the entire
year in 10 of the last 15 years.
Donald Trump paid zero in federal taxes.
How on earth is this possible?
Well, it's possible, thanks to something called
a tax loss carry forward and asset depreciation.
I'm going to explain both.
And you are very quickly going to see how
the tax code favors the super rich, as if
you didn't already know that.
So a tax loss carry forward allows you to
take a loss that happened in one year and
carry it forward to future years to reduce
the amount of tax that you owe.
So let's do like a very pedestrian example
compared to what Donald Trump is doing.
We'll do it with stocks.
Imagine that you buy twenty thousand dollars
of some stock in one year and it loses 50
percent of its value.
So you're 20000 dollars is now only 10000
dollars.
You lost 10000 dollars.
Great.
You can deduct losses.
You can deduct ten thousand dollars from your
taxes.
From the standpoint of paying capital gains
and it counts against your gains.
Beautiful.
But imagine that in the year that you lost
the 10 grand and sold the stock and realized
that loss, you only made two thousand dollars
from all of your other stock sales.
So you've got this.
Ten thousand dollar loss.
And only a two thousand dollar gain.
Well, great news.
You don't have to use the full ten thousand
dollar loss in that year.
You had a two thousand dollar gain.
You'll take just two thousand dollars from
the 10 that you lost.
And you offset a two thousand dollar gain
with a two thousand dollar loss.
You're at zero.
You pay no capital gains and your other eight
thousand dollars in losses can be carried
over to future years.
Now, maybe the next year you have a really
good year in stocks and you realize seven
thousand dollars in gains.
Well, you still have the eight thousand dollars
in loss that you carried over.
You can use another 7000 to offset the money
you made in stocks.
And again, you pay zero.
Now, that sounds reasonable enough and it's
simple enough, but that is small potatoes.
That's not how Trump takes advantage of it.
Real losses on the sale of stock are not what
Donald Trump is doing.
Donald Trump is generating paper losses with
capital losses from huge hotels and casinos.
So here is an example.
In 1995, Donald Trump reported a loss of 916
million dollars on a casino.
And we'll talk about how that loss was generated.
He then gets to take that 960 million dollar
loss and offset 50 million dollars in taxes
per year for 18 years in 2008 and 2009.
Donald Trump declared a loss of one point
four billion dollars, and he extended the
ability to carry these losses forward indefinitely
in his own tax plan, which was made effective
in 2018.
So Trump can take that one point four billion
dollar loss and just carry it forward indefinitely,
offsetting future taxes.
And the trick of it is that you can also mess
with how you declare these losses.
So we imagine listen, I buy something for
a thousand bucks and I sell it for five hundred.
I really lost 500 dollars.
That's a real loss of 500 dollars with these
huge real estate transactions and capital
investments.
There are all sorts of ways that you can move
around assets and mess with the valuation
of the assets.
I'll get back to that later to generate losses
on paper, which didn't really happen in the
way you were.
I think about losing money and you're generating
these paper losses, which you can then carry
forward.
Your average middle class working person can't
do this.
Now, the other tactic Donald Trump uses.
Where do you.
Generate these losses to carry forward, one
of the ways you can do it is with asset depreciation.
Depreciation means the value of an asset has
gone down five a car that's worth, you know,
fifteen thousand dollars when I buy it.
And after a couple years, it's worth ten thousand
dollars.
That's depreciated by 5000 dollars.
Now, with a huge real estate portfolio, you
know, a hotel, a casino, a big office building,
you don't just buy it and deduct it as a business
expense.
Like I would do with, like an audio cable
or, you know, I bought this new microphone
this year.
I'm not going to depreciate this microphone
over the next however many years.
It's too small of an expense.
I'm just going to take it as a business expense
and deduct it right away.
But with a huge hotel, you claim to have a
hotel worth five hundred million dollars.
And then now you claim, you know, the hotel
has aged, the plumbing is older.
You know, you've got to flush the toilets
10 to 15 times.
As Trump says.
You could say the hotel was worth five hundred
million.
It's now worth 250 million.
I can now take 250 million dollars in depreciation
and reduce my taxes.
And this is where the manipulations come into
play.
Michael Cohen has explained to us how Trump
does this without actually changing anything
in the real world.
If I can claim, you know, my 500 million dollar
hotel, it's really worth 600 million.
So what that means is when it goes down in
value to 250, I'm not depreciating 250 million.
I can now depreciate 350 million dollars and
create a loss carry forward that I can use
for the next however many years.
It's all imaginary.
It's all merely pushing paper.
It's accounting mechanisms.
And we know Trump did this.
The taxes prove it.
And Michael Cohen and others have told us
Donald Trump for publicity purposes or for
tax purposes or for whatever reason to get
a loan.
Trump will inflate asset values when it's
convenient or deflate asset values when it's
convenient.
These are the mechanisms Trump has used.
This is how they work.
Hopefully, it's useful to folks to understand
that